venons en maintenant au palmarès du 54e
festival de cannes je vous le disais en
commençant ce journal isabelle huppert
et benoît magimel décrochent les prix
d'interprétation pour leur rôle dans la
pianiste de l'autrichien michael haneke
qui reçoit le grand prix spécial du jury
la palme d'or elle a été attribuée à la
chambre du fils de nanni moretti michel
mompontet dont les avions quittés il ya
douze jours les revoilà 23 films plus
tard les dix membres du jury sous la
présidence de madame liv ullmann c'est
eux qui viennent mettre fin au suspense
mais dès la première grande récompense
on va comprendre vers où vont pencher
les lauriers de la gloire
isabelle huppert rôle performance rolf
ou et démesurée dans la pianiste
qu'irait du fabuleux roman d'elfriede
jelinek elle incarne une professeure de
piano dont la libido se résume à la
fréquentation 17 choc
loin des sentiments qui seul s'adresse à
la musique
alors je remercie bach schubert et
mozart encore la pianiste mais cette
fois ci pour le prix d'interprétation
masculine
benoît magimel qu'on avait découvert il
ya 14 ans dans la vie est un long fleuve
tranquille
il est dans ce film l'élève de la
pianiste celui qui la fera craquer pour
ce film donc carton plein du côté des
acteurs
mais ce n'est pas fini toujours et
encore la pianiste et le cinéaste
autrichien michael haneke grand prix du
jury un an après l'échec du film le code
inconnu
voici michael hanecke sur le toit du
monde
leakey l'année qu'est trois fois décoré
trois fois honoré je suis vraiment ému
que notre film maintenant je suis trois
prises c'est extraordinaire je la voie
était donc libre pour l'archi favori de
cette compétition le réalisateur italien
nanni moretti et la chambre du fils le
seul film qui aura véritablement fait
d'unanimité sur la croisette sa
quatrième visite à cannes sera donc la
bonne
la chambre du fils un film grave et
émouvant sur la disparition d'un enfant
dans la vie d'une paisible famille
italienne réalisée par les jeunes
réalisateurs italiens dont on comprenne
tout même lorsqu'il ne parle qu'en
italien et lorsqu'ils paient aussi eu si
beau cinéma vainqueur par défaut diront
les grincheuses vainqueur magnifique
d'abord et avant tout